I'm not afraid of death this is a healer
this can be a friend when you were in
constant agonizing pain when you put me
on your meat table you would be shocked
because I have read all the words
running across my body from my head to
my toes wiggling tracks from surgeries I
really didn't care anymore if I went on
one more day and then the visible human
came along and I said maybe God wants me
to do another project I think I've left
enough of a heritage behind that there
will be enough to remember by my spirit
will live on my soul will live on my
physical body belongs to dr. Spitzer
[Music]
[Music]
I take care of the dead I don't I'm not
a health care provider I'm a trained PhD
in physical chemistry and my background
was in physics and math so I had no
relationship whatsoever to biology I
came to the University of Colorado in
1977 and at that point in time the
anatomy department was quite interested
in creating information with the human
body cadavers the way anatomist teach so
they hired me to try and develop this
expertise I hadn't developed any
particular love for any piece of anatomy
I loved the human body it's just
fascinating and I didn't know much about
it I like to describe Vik he's kind of a
mad scientist kind of guy he's got all
these brilliant ideas and he's
passionate about everything and Vik just
does whatever he wants and I mean
ultimately that's how he's able to do
such impressive projects the visible
human project was designed by the
National Library of Medicine the primary
goal was education in the old days if
you wanted to develop three-dimensional
anatomy of the human body for purposes
of teaching students the technique was
basically to section the body into slabs
when Vik appeared on the scene with his
expertise in computer technology it was
like manna from heaven we wanted to take
photographic slices through a person's
body and you can't photograph the inside
with visible light unless it's a cadaver
the visible human dissectors so that's
the original body that we sliced that
software's used a lot in medical schools
and it's mainly a way to teach Anatomy
in a 3d space this was done in the 90s
in order to get really thin slices the
only way we knew how to do it was to
freeze it coated with polyvinyl alcohol
to protect from freezer burn and then
you couldn't section the body into four
blocks each less than 20 inches after
that we'd process each block by by
turning it into literally a block by
surrounding it in PVA or plastic and
then we take off one millimeter at a
time of that block and take a picture of
the remainder of the block so once we
have the section of the specimen that we
want to cut we have a circular blade
that rotates and the blade moves down
incrementally on that specimen to the
naked eye you can't see the difference
but after seven days you made it through
an entire body the grinding or shaving
process is a lot like an industrial
sized sanding if you were to take a
electric sander and stay on the service
of wood and then take a picture and then
sand it again
take a picture those tiny changes that
start to occur that's what we're
capturing all the way through this body
we end up taking a lot of photographs
something like 20,000 pictures then we
digitally align those up so that as you
scroll through you can move from head to
show through the entire body dealing
with cadavers and donations of people's
bodies to medical education it's been
going on for a long time
Susan Potter is quite different
and I don't think you know why yet we
did a member in our presence today you
may have noticed her she's in a
wheelchair let me be very
straightforward about this she wants to
be hated
she had a newspaper article Rocky
Mountain News that described the visible
human in great detail and that's what
made her want to be part of this kind of
educational process for medical students
it's easy to write a prescription it's
easy to give an injection or to take you
to the surgery and cut you up that's all
easy there's more to it than that
and that is my project through the
invisible disability woman to bring
information and teaching to the medical
profession to the entire healthcare
profession she rolled into the reception
area in the center for human simulation
and she said I want to be part of this
very emphatically and told me about her
diseases and her history and I said well
you're a walking pathology specimen not
an Anatomy specimen we're trying to
teach normal and you're not normal she
wouldn't quit she just kept saying I
want to do this and I thought about
something I'd seen earlier about someone
that was dead talking to you I said if
you will let us record your life for the
next year then I will commit to doing
this we didn't know it was gonna be 12
years
last fifty years two different elements
of society but most recently you made a
decision to donate not just your life I
have always felt that there is a lot to
be learned in medicine in society and if
I could be a small part of it having
been involved with hospitals and
children that my body was always ready
for donation what she really wanted was
to be helpful to medical students to
people learning an enemy she really
wanted those students to understand
compassion so she was happy to talk
about compassion at health care while
she was living it is not just liver with
a gallbladder or the stomach but it is
the whole being that being dealt with
and as far as I'm concerned there is not
enough education going on in the medical
school or nursing schools or anywhere
else that makes people realize that
human beings are need to be treated as a
whole that's what's important to me she
knew the intimacy's of sectioning a body
the way we do she actually rolled her
wheelchair into the freezer and looked
at the cutting system that we use the
first time I went to the Institute and
George as I call him mister be human and
I said okay how did he get it to be that
way let's see what you do you said you
don't want to look at it as it is I do
especially if you're going to do it to
me what is the first thing you do when
you get a take-off is Liberty and it
doesn't frighten me
you have to realize this is just your
body that's going to be cut up and if
that body that has served you all these
years and we won't say how well you have
done something that leaves a legacy
behind Susan passed away early in the
morning she had pneumonia and I last saw
her in University Hospital
there are processes sent out to pick up
a cadaver and bring it to the state on
top of a board and that was all set in
place
I went over some time in that morning
and looked at her it was a bit emotional
just saying her that that was the end of
it after that it was my job so our goal
here is to decide where to section and
we want to get her entire heart in the
picture and it's almost finished
right there and there it is finished
I have difficulty dealing with some
aspects of cadavers but I was trying to
do things for her she wanted this to
come to a close and there was a sense of
fulfillment there when we would talk
about what was happening to her in the
freezer I wanted to make darn sure she
understood and she would oftentimes ask
for a blanket I said Susan that's absurd
I'm not going to cut a blanket but she
asked for roses I said I will do that
[Music]
that is going to go exactly to the same
place where my tulips cats are they've
gone to a better world and so rely
[Music]
[Music]
this is her patio she had a lot of
flowers on her on her patio
she brought plastic flowers to me
constantly she wanted she wanted my
laboratory over there to look nicer I
had to give her a hug every time I left
her which I didn't wanted to do it first
because I'm not a hundred but I did
because she she needed it I was happy to
do it if that's what she really needed
so we were friends
dissecting a body with a sharp scalpel
sounds nicer to me than taking that same
body apart with a machine but if we
really think all we are is a bunch of
tissue it shouldn't matter
[Music]
I always during her life
wanted to improve our cutting improve
our imaging now I've got to do what I
said I would do and that is do the best
we can at imaging her because that's
what I committed to
this is the most high quality imagery
taken of an entire human body that
exists and I think ultimately that's
what Susan wanted was to do something
revolutionary and that's what they've
done
so I think this project together the two
of them creating this I think it's a
huge part of who he is this is this is
life work well developed just because
it's easier to teach so here comes a
lady with 26 surgeries
breast cancer melanoma the cervical
screws and wires and a replaced hip
that's what I told her I said interested
but she was persistent we'll scroll
through the cross section to adjust what
it looks like over here Susan Potter is
more than 2 terabytes of data and we're
working with the top block only and
trying to process those images then
we'll work with the three other blocks
and then there's the bigger task yet to
put the four blocks together her images
as well as her talking that's all part
of the data set which people can see if
you just ignore the rest of the data
throw away all the videotape just look
at the anatomy there's a lot there but
when you tie it to the humanity of the
videotapes and her life I thought that
would be very impactful in the lobby
today are you very very very positive
that my body with all the screws and
wires and all that stuff in it and all
the bony bumps will be able to be used
on you and I said to you if you can't I
would like you to tell me right now I
said well I guess not
and in God's sake please let me stay
around a little longer
Along Came Doctor best pizza in George
and I felt very much cold that this was
something I needed to get involved with
what her feelings about her talking to
you when I first took you know human
gross anatomy I think what was always
repeated by professors was that look
these are you know these were humans and
these were people and they gave their
bodies to us so we have to be respectful
don't really there's sort of a sense of
immortality did she care about that I
honestly don't think she cared about the
immortality of being up on the screen
for the next 20 years and seeing every
part of her body I don't think she cared
about that but she did care about making
medical education better you're right
it's emotional I constantly told her I
am NOT your friend but I was and she
thought I was her friend and and I she
was my friend but I didn't want that
this reveals a lot to me about her life
I was accused of keeping her alive just
because she was living for donating to
be part of this project I have problems
with what we do talk about death I don't
like the idea of worms crawling in and
out of my body and my body decaying and
and turning to dust but we're projecting
lifelike experiences on death
logically I have no no problem with it
emotionally I do you don't intend to
stop petting our intention is to go to
higher resolution better pictures
getting this all to a process where we
really could virtual eyes on hundred
bodies we're trying to simulate the
human being
[Music]
[Music]